okay if you are protesting now or if you
plan to protest someday you should
really know your rights what is the law
and what is beyond the law so that you
can be prepared to advocate for yourself
and others if you see protesters rights
being violated and so that you can
remain safe now I know I don't even have
to say this but of course if you break
the law including by damaging property
or attacking people you are at risk of
getting arrested and of getting the crap
kicked out of you by the way the way
things seem to be going with police and
nothing in this video is meant to help
people break the law the point is to
understand the law and understand what
you're legally allowed to do so first of
all the core of this is that the First
Amendment of the to the Constitution of
the United States grants you the right
to assemble and to use your voice to
protest using your voice includes things
like holding signs as well it is legal
for law enforcement to ban protesters
from certain physical spaces for example
if law enforcement says you can't walk
on the highway to protest and there's
already most states have rules against
walking on the highway anyway and you do
it you can get arrested for that if
there is a curfew and you ignore it to
protest you can get arrested where
things get tricky is in the gray area
when you have 99% of a protest being
peaceful and 1% starts breaking the law
the police do have the right to clear
the entire protest and you can get
arrested even if you weren't doing
anything wrong if after police have said
it's time to go you stick around now
police are not supposed to immediately
start arresting and tear gassing and
hitting people with batons if they say
protest has to end they wait five
seconds and they start beating the crap
out of people they're supposed to
provide a reasonable amount of time for
people to get out of the area and if you
are what clearly walking away you also
should not be bothered or attacked by
police now this is as you can imagine
dangerous because these rules can be
misused police can incite a couple of
people to break the law to then justify
clearing an entire
protests that's a way in which police
can misuse these rules but understand
that when part of a protest has gone bad
legally I'm not saying morally legally
police can clear the entire area now in
terms of where you can protest I
mentioned highways could be off-limits
that would not be considered a
limitation of your First Amendment
rights if police say you can't walk on
the highway and do your protests there
there are states that require permits if
you're going to be in the street or
sometimes on the sidewalk if you're not
going to be moving and you're going to
be blocking traffic now a pedestrian
traffic generally you do not need
permits to protest while walking along
sidewalks or even in streets sometimes
if you are not obstructing traffic
depends on the state it's very hard to
protest on a road without obstructing
traffic so the road protests almost
always do need a permit generally
speaking public spaces can be protest
locations that include sidewalks and
parks and the like doesn't mean you can
do it without a permit in some states
you must know the laws of your state
anytime that you block the passage of
people or cars and this includes on
sidewalks you can be arrested if you
refuse to move understand that and again
this can be misused by police police
will sometimes say you're blocking
pedestrian traffic and then say and
because of that it's time to wrap it up
and then you stay and you get arrested
even though traffic may not actually
have been blocked police are supposed to
provide a reasonable opportunity to
comply and that includes sufficient time
and a clear unobstructed exit path we
had reports from yesterday that
protesters were sort of corralled onto
one of the bridges in between Manhattan
and Brooklyn I believe the Manhattan
Bridge and that would be in violation of
if you say it's time to go you have to
provide an unobstructed exit path and
time to exit now this means that they
can't say the party's over and within 15
seconds start arresting people but it is
sometimes misused by police to claim we
issued a dispersal order and they didn't
move
um quick note about government buildings
government buildings can be exceptions
they there's sort of public buildings in
a sense that doesn't mean you can
necessarily protest inside and that
varies by state very important if you
want to show up and record with your
phone or with a camera or whatever you
can record what is going on in public
and you can record police no matter what
they tell you again the trick to watch
out for is that if by recording you are
impeding police where you've decided to
stand if you're getting in the way of
what police are doing they can argue you
are interfering with police you're
obstructing law enforcement as you can
imagine that can also be misused and you
can find examples of police saying that
somebody who's really not obstructing is
obstructing by virtue of where they're
standing to record the advice we
generally see is stand on the sidewalk
to record if the altercation is
happening on the sidewalk make sure that
you're not in the way of police now in
terms of recording you are also
protesting in a public space meaning you
can be recorded your picture can be
taken your face could be published in
media without your consent understand
that when you go to a protest you're not
starting an altercation because
someone's filming you but they do film
you and then that is used somewhere that
is legal because you are out in public
at a protest police do have pretty broad
rights to maintain law and order and
uphold local laws and this can sometimes
be Mis applied to filming be aware
police can't tell you that you have to
turn over your phone they can't force
you to show them stuff on your phone
they need a warrant signed by a judge in
order to do that now if police approach
you because you are recording certainly
remind the police that recording in a
public space is number one of course
legal and number two does not count as
reasonable suspicion to believe you have
committed a crime in other words if
police say there they're approaching you
because you're acting suspiciously and
all you're doing is filming filming does
not count
as reasonable suspicion if you do break
the law and get a
austan the normal search and seizure
rules would apply if police tell you
you've got a deleted video from your
phone that is not a lawful order from
police and you don't have to do it if
police want to search your backpack or
your wallet or your fanny pack before or
after an arrest you're under no
obligation to allow it and you can even
say I do not consent to a search of my
property
police typically are allowed to Pat you
down
in some states you do have to give
police your name but you are not
required to give any other information
remember counter-protesters that might
not agree with you also have free speech
rights and police are supposed to treat
both protesters and counter protesters
equally according to the ACLU police are
permitted if they identify antagonistic
groups police are permitted to keep
those groups separated but they should
allow them to be within sight and sound
of each other otherwise you're not
really able to protest you're not really
able to counter protest if you can only
do it out of earshot and visible range
of the people you are protesting so then
a few notes on police interactions if
police approached you and you and want
to talk to you you don't have to talk to
them but don't resist of course it's
better not to run away but simply ask am
I being detained or am I free to go if
they say you were not free to go you are
able to inquire what is the crime I'm
suspected of having committed that has
caused you to detain me if you do get
arrested you also don't have to say
anything again in some states you do
have to state your name but in many
states you don't the degree of
cooperation you want to exhibit is up to
you depends on what you've been doing
depends on your priorities at any time
you can ask for a lawyer and they are
required to provide you one now can you
be fired by your employer for being at a
protest even if you didn't do anything
illegal even if your participation is
protected by the Constitution
unfortunately the answer answers it
depends it depends on the state you live
and work in it depends on what kind of
job you have it depends on what kind of
agreement you have in place with your
employer if you have one a lot of people
don't really have such a green
and that one is more complicated and you
should really discuss it with a lawyer
or legal aid service but there are many
circumstances in which your employer can
dismiss you merely for having
participated in a constitutionally
protected protest very important to
understand the law and your rights when
it comes to that let me know if I missed
anything important make sure you are
following me on Twitter at de Pakman and
make sure you're subscribed to the daily
audio podcast on iTunes stitcher Spotify
and Google Play or anywhere you prefer
to get your podcast we'll take a quick
break and be back after this